شيرين مواطنه بريطانيه تلقت رساله هذا
الصباح من خدمه الصحه الوطنيه تبلغها
بتاجيل موعدها حتى يوليو المقبل ما يعني
انها ستضطر الى تحمل الم تعاني منه منذ
سنوات في عمودها الفقري املها الا يتسبب
الانتظار بتفاقم وضعها الصحي
تلقيت رساله هذا الصباح تبلغني ان موعدي
تاجل حتى نهايه يوليو ما يعني اني ساتحمل
الالم لبضعه اشهر اخرى وقد تزداد المشكله
سوءا الغاء موعد شيرين من ضمن 350 الف
موعد طبي ملغى او مؤجل لاشخاص سيتاثرون
بالاضرابات المستمره حتى عطله نهايه
الاسبوع المطالب رفع الاجور بنسبه 35%
نسبه قالت النقابات انها تاخذ بالاعتبار
السنوات الخمسه عشره الاخيره التي لم تشهد
زياده عادله نسبه ترفضها الحكومه وترى
انها غير واقعيه
[موسيقى]
التقينا بالسيد باركلي مرتين حتى الان في
المره الاولى لم يكن لديه اي تفويض
لمناقشه الاجور اما المره الثانيه التي
التقينا به لم يقدم لنا عرضا بل وخرج من
المفاوضات
الهدف بالنسبه للاطباء ليس انيا وانما في
طياته بعد نظر قبل انهيار القطاع الصحي
بالكامل اذا ظل كما هو الان
هذه الاضرابات ضروريه لتحسين الوضع الصحي
على الرغم من انها تتسبب بازمه على المدى
القصير لكن امل حقا ان يفهم المرضى اننا
نفعل ذلك ليس فقط من اجلنا ولكن ايضا من
اجلهم
الدكتور احمد هو الاخر من مرضى القلب
الذين يقيمون في بريطانيا منذ عام 82 ياسف
على تغير حال القطاع الصحي في البلاد
كمريض قلب مباشره
بيقطعوا كل شيء وبياخذوني لجوا ويحطوني
فاما الناس الثانيين يا حرام عما ينتظروا
كثير ساعات وساعات
في تاخير مواعيد المرضى الذين يعانون
بالاساس من لوائح انتظار عليها
اكثر لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات